mehr als 70 expertinnen und experten aus
wirtschaft und politik haben sich auch
in diesem jahr zum world economic forum
in davos getroffen und über nichts
geringeres beraten als über unsere
zukunft über die wirklich großen
globalen fragen dieser welt was sind die
größten gefahren wie wird sich unser
leben in den nächsten jahren ändern
werden internet gegangen wie google und
so weiter die macht übernehmen und
inwieweit sind regierungen weltweit eine
gefahr für unsere jetzige zivilisation
ihr habt euch dieses spannende thema
whatsapp gewünscht und bekommt jetzt die
drei wichtigsten fragen dazu beantwortet
herzlich willkommen bei klicks um
science-fiction
ja und wir täglich an die neuesten infos
auf whatsapp kommt und bei klick zum
mitmachen können dass der vater am ende
des videos auf der 3 werden wir heimlich
von internet giganten regiert als einer
von vielen warnte beispielsweise der
ungarische mehr der jobs for
allmächtigen internetgiganten diese
seien schon seit längerer zeit dabei
immer mächtiger zu werden und könnten
sich im worst case auch mit autoritären
regime verbünden vielleicht sagen einige
von euch die science fiction storys von
george orwell oder aldous huxley etwas
auch in ihren romanen geht es um
überwachung szenarien die der realen
welt lockt source vielleicht allerdings
schon bald in nichts mehr nachstehen
als längst überfällig bezeichnete der
investor mehr regeln für die konzerne
beispielsweise durch die
eu-wettbewerbskommission kleiner fun
fact am rande während der rede von
source die immer größer werdende macht
von facebook google und so weiter
anmahnte waren die zuschauer des world
economic forums fleißig dabei seine
äußerung genau in diesen sozialen
netzwerken zu teilen
aber die antwort lautet source also ja
sie sind ziemlich mächtig und zwar bald
schon übermächtig und wir müssen etwas
dagegen tun
ja war ein krasses statement auf der
zwei werden einzelne herrscher kriege
provozierend einige experten experten
das geld konnte vor uns sehen auf
verschiedene regierungen weltweit als
entscheidender knackpunkt für unsere
zukunft vor allem der amerikanische
präsident donald trump wird von vielen
als echte gefahr gesehen auch dazu hat
sich der ungarische investor george
soros geäußert in den vereinigten
staaten würde präsident kommt gerne
einen mafia staat errichten aber er
schafft es nicht die verfassung andere
institutionen und die lebendige ziel
gesellschaft stehen dem entgegen ähnlich
wie kim jong un in nordkorea habe er
keine scheu atomwaffen einzusetzen das
sei ein großes risiko für die gesamte
menschheit als große gefahr wurde auch
der wachsende rechtspopulismus in europa
identifiziert laut der deutschen
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel gift das
von ungelösten problemen angetrieben
werden und tatsächlich muss der
wachsende rechtspopulismus schleunigst
unter kontrolle gebracht werden
mehr der songs geht noch weiter und
bezeichnet das parteiensystem in
deutschland als weitestgehend unfähig
seine erklärung dazu durch das
auftauchen der afg sei die csu weiter
nach rechts gerutscht zwischen den
unionsparteien sei und unüberbrückbarer
graben entstanden also auch hier werden
große gefahren durch autokratische
regime und die entwicklung der
parteienlandschaft gesehen auf der eins
sorgen digitalisierung und künstliche
intelligenz für eine spaltung der
gesellschaft fest steht digitalisierung
und künstliche intelligenz ki haben ein
riesiges potenzial aber natürlich werden
wir als gesellschaft auch mit
entsprechenden konsequenzen leben müssen
auch das war ein heiß diskutiertes thema
unter den mehr als 70 expertinnen und
experten hier wird befürchtet dass ein
solcher fortschritt in diesen bereichen
zu wenig menschen zugute kommen wird die
sprache ist von einer technisch globalen
elite und lokal frustrierten auf der
anderen seite eine spaltung der
gesellschaft wäre dann die folge einige
derjenigen die diese warnung offen
aussprechen kommen selbst aus
amerikanischen technologiekonzern unter
anderem ihnen maske oder auch der apple
mitbegründer steve wozniak studien
zeigen dass vor allem in den usa die
angst vor technik getriebene
arbeitslosigkeit sehr groß ist macht
bald eine maschine meinen job das
deutsche ausbildungssystem könnte eine
lösung sein menschen so zu qualifizieren
dass sie sich auch in einer veränderten
arbeitswelt zurechtfinden diese drei
themengebiete waren womit die
wichtigsten und fest steht alle werden
unsere zukunft maßgeblich mitbestimmen
wenn als erstes neues zum thema zukunft
der menschheit und zu allen anderen
themen erfahren wollt dann endet meine
telefonnummer hierbei whatsapp dann
erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen
vom neuesten video täglich garantiert
ihr könnt uns direkt über mich in der
redaktion von krieg zum mitmachen und
mit
bestimmen was hierbei kriegs um so
passiert und zur begrüßung habe ich ein
kleines geschenk für euch parat einfach
hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht
das abo mit der glocke vergessen
und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch
draufklicken führt syrien zum dritten
weltkrieg was wäre wenn ansonsten bis
dann blatter